ils vivent parfois au bord des routes
nationales pas forcément loin de paris
mais toujours loin de ceux qui les
dirigent leur vie ressemble assez peu à
ce qu'on voit à la télé ils ont le
sentiment d'être des français de seconde
zone comme s'ils étaient invisibles ces
français ne veulent plus se taire ils
ont des choses à dire la france oubliée
c'est une rencontre avec ces citoyens
qui ne se résignent pas à la fatalité la
france oubliée c'est montrer ce qu'on ne
voit jamais
aujourd'hui je me rends à biomasse est
située sur le massif du mont blanc
[Musique]
ça lui va bien bonjour c'est le bout du
monde ici on est bien
j'ai cru que j'arrivais jamais c'est là
si si ça se trouve toujours bien passé
ça se mérite
ah ouais ça se mérite à quelques
paysages et bien voilà le brouillard
sinon on est bien on à quelle hauteur là
on a le 14 cents d'altitude
bon là on est chez toi ouais à la ferme
à la ferme
ah ben on va te suivra les allées ne je
pose mon bois et on y va on y va c'est
parti donc là on est sur la commune de
saint-gervais tout à fait si abou thiam
aulas on a une trentaine d'habitants à
l'année ça sert peuple est un peu il ya
des maisons qui se construisent pas mal
de résidents secondaires donc toi tu
fais moutons cui pour la viande pour la
viande exclusivement exclusivement en
circuits courts souvent à super u et au
sinon je vends tout aux particuliers
dans quoi d'accord du roman circuits
courts c'est un petit élevage et que 80
brebis il y en a qui sont nés là oui on
va voir ça c'est un travail en a deux
hier soir et une à l'âge et hank azaria
voilà parfait tu es là depuis des
générations
nous c'est la moi je suis la quatrième
génération de la quatrième génération de
bien là c'est ton grand père il est
arrivé 12 août et mon arrière grand père
il était de d'italie dit allez on est
des cousins italiens suisses
on est tous de la vallée de la coi ouais
parce que dans la région la cci talent
il est tout à côté la suisse pareil
c'est pareil on est celle élan d'amour
voyant la montagne là je vous présente
le gard ma chienne de protection donc ça
ce n'est pas tout ce n'est pas tout j'en
ai un l'âge est là la grande naïve et le
petit là bas derrière là j'ai mes brebis
mais parce que le principe donc il ya
des chiens de protection
voilà contre les loups plus en plus
c'est pour louer parce qu'il naisse en
fait ces chiens là dans les îles visant
les troupes voilà ils vivent dans les
moutons en permanence ils se prennent
pour des moutons tout le temps je vais
vous cherchez j'en ai une caffè latte à
leur jeu vous cherchez l'agneau saas et
les nouveaux nés
voilà donc la ilaha illa un jour les
lainiers hier soir minuit j'en ai que
vous qu'on fait là
et c'est par mois cette année j'ai subi
cinq attaques en tout j'en ai perdu une
trentaine de brebis avec les animaux
tout quoi j'ai une brebis elle avait des
petits agneaux un peu comme ça les
animaux sont morts après parce qu'ils
n'avaient plus leur mère moi la dernière
attaque j'ai eu là derrière la maison là
là où il ya les enfants qui jouent là
d'un mètre donc ils font ça pour ce
louis rossi lui pour se nourrir oui et
non parce que qu'ils feraient que pour
se nourrir ils ont duré pas autant voilà
la première attaque canal et six sur
terre était juste égorgée juste égorgée
juste et lors des essais récents comme
phénomène szavay 2 3 3 en 4 ans être on
en parlait on entendait envoyer des
traces on avait quelques prédation mais
c'était vraiment leur art vraiment rare
et maintenant il y en a vraiment des
loups implanté vraiment voilà c'est bien
c'est autre chose quoi et tu de membres
est quoi le le droit de pouvoir
voilà déjà effarouchées repoussé louer
et quand on voit qu'on a on a des zones
qui sont plus à risque qu'on a eu le
droit d'être libres à les protéger
comment comme on fait quoi c'est à dire
que t'as même pas le droit de tirer que
j'ai des autorisations de tir on a fait
des formations des autorisations de tir
et tout mais pour mettre en place c'est
hyper compliqué la géographie du terrain
les et ses immenses et ses monstres du
rapport qui sait nous on est elle l
habitude c'était de lâcher les brebis
l'été dans des petites montagnes et
prend les récupérer l'auteur mais
maintenant c'est fini on peut plus faire
comme ça et pour les gars d'en bas on va
les agneaux grossissent pas aussi bien
les brebis sont pas aussi bien parce
qu'il ya la chaleur il y à deux fois
deux de deux élevages il y en a 1 2 3
qui ont arrêté du fait des attaques de
loups essais des alpages qui se vide et
c'est des montagnes qui est la
végétation repoussé tous des arbres et
si ça continue comme ça dans quelques
années on verra plus les montagnes
paraguay à vous ça se remet où la nature
reprend ses droits c'est tous des arbres
et à cause de quoi ça passe quand on ne
sait plus et plus exploités par les
spots et la petite agriculture de
montagne comme on fait donc là c'est un
peu ta passion les risques c'est
vraiment une passion parce que c'était
pas ça pour l'argent tu gagnes pas ta
vie avec ça je n'aime pas du tout ça
travaille ça te rapporte combien sur une
année globe
si j'arrive à de sortir de bénéfices à
la fin d'une année j'ai à peu près 500
euros ah oui mais sans compter les
heures sans compter les heures de
tracteur à faire des points à remettant
en état des champs sans voilà raccord
donc son beauf des sous pour sega que le
brouillard c'est humide à les laisser
tranquilles se reposer hier mon collègue
saluer les bons mais ça va tout va bien
pour toi c'est pierre pierre oui c'est
ça touati aussi dans la manière
ouais donc toi tu es et ce que tu
exploite des vaches
oui moi j'ai des chaînes une que du lait
du fromage ça au début quand je me suis
installé
je me suis installé en 2011 et en fait
quand tu t'installes les premières
années bien souvent elles sont
difficiles t'arrives pas à tirer de
revenu lâche est une chèvre va pas de
faire du là tout de suite du jour au
lendemain et puis tu vas pas réussir ton
premier fromage du jour au lendemain et
donc ben même si c'est assez prenants
faut quand même trouver une source de
revenu c'est pour ça qu'en montagne tu
as beaucoup d'agriculteurs qui sont plus
réactifs en fait c'est à dire qu'ils
font les fonds de saison d'hiver et donc
toi tu as en revanche un autre boulot
oui dans les canons à neige se serait tu
as fait tu travailles ou ch à manille à
chamonix
donc la balle a en ce moment ça c'est
compliqué mais sinon bah je fais la
journée à la compagnie là au boulot à
chamonix
elle sort je m'occupe de mes moutons
l'attaquant était en chômage chômage on
est au chômage
mais toi pierre donc que la même
problématique par rapport au loup il a
aujourd'hui on sait qu'il ya des meutes
implanté domicile et a aussi tenu des
pertes santé alors pas direct parce que
on a deux patous on a des parcs de nuit
en conséquence dépens de nuit donc en
fait c'est un endroit où groupe les
troupeaux la nuit oui
donc en fait on met en place au 15 juin
quand on monte avec les chères et puis
on démonte au 15 septembre donc ça veut
dire que tout l'été les chevaux elle
passe la nuit et le nombre d'accords et
ça pose un autre problème c'est le
problème du parasitisme et la première
année moi j'ai perdu 7 chèvres au moment
des mises bas à cause de ça parce que
les chèvres étaient complètement
attristé de verre à l'intérieur
et malgré les traitements on n'a pas
réussi à les sauver donc c'est pas
perdre direct via le loup elle se sont
pas fait attaquer par louise sont pas
failli et gorgée j'ai pas eue et le fait
de les parquer ou même serein dans la
promiscuité et c'est tout les mêmes
endroits les autres
un lit de crottes en fait le seul brin
d'herbe qui pousse bas elles vont manger
au fur et à mesure et voilà est décédé
pertes qu'on parle pas parce que ben on
voit pas la chèvre morte sur le bord du
chemin avec du sang autour mais elles
sont quand même là qu'on sait quoi
d'entendre tous les débats de protection
de la nature de l'écologie qui doit
vraiment devenir nouveau mode de vie
pour tous les français à ce qu'on fasse
ça se comprend nous de toute façon je
pense qu'en agriculture de montagne et
écologie on est quand même assez proche
puisque c'est une agriculture raisonnée
nous on n'est pas en bio parce que on
peut pas du fait que les vaches sont
sont une étape traditionnelle l'hiver
donc le bio l'interdît mais mais on a
toutes les pratiques bio en fait on se
fait ça fait 25 ans qu'on met 0 apport
chimique sur nos parcelles et ce qui est
difficile à subir c'est que tu es dans
ta montagne tu te fais attaquer donc en
fait t'as le tas cette notion
d'impuissance face au lou parce qu'il va
t'attaquer et en plus de ça il faut que
tu supportes les critiques des ddd
pseudo écologique où je sais pas comment
on peut les appeler et puis aujourd'hui
les réseaux sociaux c'est un c c'est une
explosion de critiques et de haine qui
est ce que tel sentiment d'être à la
fois peu oublié incompris du grand
public
ouais alors faut pas mettre tout le
grand public dans la salle parce que
c'est une minorité
quand même qui critiquent vraiment
violemment la profession mais le défaut
qu'on a eu au niveau agriculture ce
qu'on n'ait jamais su communiquer on n'a
jamais su expliquer nos manières de
fonctionner pourquoi on travaillait
comme ça pourquoi on faisait ça tu es
l'époque pourquoi et ben on épand lisier
dans les champs et
ex à 100 pourquoi aujourd'hui on essaye
un peu de combler salle et surtout en
zones touristiques
c'est pour ça qu'on ouvre notre ferme on
est bienvenue à la ferme on fait des
visites mais donc s'asseoir jeu par
l'éducation par la pj tu as fait ouais
mais certains il critiqueront ils
viendront y viendrons jamais voir et ils
auront leur avis assez seconde raison
est venu voir comment on travaille venez
voir ce qu'on ce qu'on subit moi j'ai
dormi 30 nuit dans mon 4 4 pour pour
protéger mon troupeau cet été et
j'allais au travail j'ai mangé manger et
à dormir dans mon cas de 4 mai qui avait
quelque chose faisait du bruit au machin
j'ai protégé un peu comme ça plus les
chiens et voilà c'est ça ça on s'en rend
pas compte
personne n'en parle ça après moi je
prends mes vacances pour faire des faux
pour fermer points et puis pour faire un
être les agneaux et voilà moi mes
vacances et quand je suis là chez moi
avec mes moutons
ouais t'as pas besoin d'aller au bord de
l'eau non non tu restes passé plat le
pelage blanc exotiques
non non mais on parle de pollution
aujourd'hui mais c'est peut-être ça
aussi la pollution
c'est peut-être ça s'était arrêté
peut-être d'aller faire des voyages à
tout bout partout dans le monde avec des
avions qui polluent et machin quoi parce
que aujourd'hui on nous parle de plus
manger de la viande est tout ouïe on
élève nos animaux pour les manger
mais c'est pas industriel et rien
d'industriel ya vraiment familial c'est
vraiment des petits troupeaux c'est
vraiment des petits abattoirs a fait
vraiment du il porte à porte
moi les gens ils viennent chercher la
nuit là dans la cour quoi si tu avais un
souhait pour la france idéale
tu dirais quoi hormis le fait de
demander l'indépendance de la haute
savoie ça j'ai compris voilà on veut ça
d'accord ça détruit sa coupe à 50 fois
sais c'est que les gens reviennent à des
vraies valeurs
parce qu'aujourd'hui on les a perduré
beaucoup ont perdu les valeurs
aujourd'hui on voit les gens ils
arrivent ici c'est un cadre magnifique
premier truc c'est en a pas d'internet
c'est ça n'est autre chose
on a vu des gamins l'aïki qui sont là
ils font de la luge toute la journée
tous voilà il ya autre chose dans la vie
que internet et tout ça fauves revenir
des vraies valeurs
les vraies valeurs de la vie du poids
qu'on allait tous les bonnes mais ouais
on a des bonnes valeurs quand même
encore en montagne
bon les gars là inventif à sion à faire
la photo on finit toujours la séquence
par une photo on va retourner à l'état
plaisir avec la news c'est sympa elle va
aller avec plaisir on y va c'est parti
alors à peu chez vous
je
[Musique]